لا حياه خاصه لسكان البلده القديمه في
القدس فبجانب الانتشار المكثف لعناصر
الشرطه الاسرائيليه تم نصب كاميرات
المراقبه في كل حارات البلده وان افلت من
مضايقات الشرطه فلن تفلت من مضايقات
المستوطنين الذين يحملون اسلحه مرخصه من
قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
باب الدار امكانيه على الباب يمكن
100 مره
عشان الاذان
خطر دق وان المحاولات الاسرائيليه لتغيير
الوضع الراهن باتت اقرب من قبل من خلال
الاستمرار في السيطره على المنازل وحسب
الاحصائيات الاسرائيليه هناك زياده اثنين
في المئه بنسبه السكان اليهود في البلده
شباب
القصص هذه حرق بيوت كل العالم
وفي السياق ذاته يشكل الفلسطينيون من
الضرائب الباهضه التي فرضتها بلديه القدس
التابعه للسلطات الاسرائيليه على المحل
التجاريه كادت ضغط على المقدسيين والذين
باتوا غير قادرين على دفعها ما ادى الى
اغلاق اكثر من 200 و 250 محلا تجاريا
ابوابها
السياسه الاسرائيليه اليمنيه التي تتمثل
بمنع الترميم والاستيلاء على منازل
الفلسطينيين جنبا الى سماح بتسليح
المستوطنين ومضايقتها من السكان هي مجرد
ادواته لتغيير الديموغرافيا في القدس
لصالح المستوطنين وهذا ما يقوله
الفلسطينيون هنا لان كل غاصي من داخل
البلد القديمه في القدس العربيه